la manifestation est partie en début
d'après midi de la place de la
république pour atteindre en fin de
journée la place de la bastille et
quelques milliers de personnes ont
participé à ce rassemblement pour
demander la libération immédiate de
khaled and rare ni ceux journalistes de
tv5-monde correspondant de reporters
sans frontières avait été arrêté à la
fin du mois de mars après avoir couvert
une manifestation du kerax mouvement de
contestation inédit qui a secoué
l'algérie pendant plus d'un an que son
procès en appel
et dans deux jours en première instance
il a été condamné à une peine de trois
ans de prison pour incitation
attroupement et atteinte à l'unité
nationale ses proches dénoncent une
incarcération arbitraire injuste je vous
propose de les écouter le message est
clair c'est un message d'union c'est un
message d'espoir c'est un message de
lutte démocratique qui naquit ne
s'arrête pas c'est des femmes des hommes
des vieux des gamins qui viennent
aujourd'hui affirmer notre volonté
commune d'aller vers un état
démocratique vers une démocratie majeure
nous sommes là ici pour dénoncer les
arrestations arbitraires les détenus
politiques les journalistes injustement
emprisonnées nous sommes là algérienne
algériens toutes tendances confondues
qui croyant à la démocratie qui croyant
à cette lutte de tout un peuple depuis
l'indépendance
c'est le grand message aujourd'hui à la
place de la république fait on est là à
la place de la république pour dire au
peuple algérien
qui souffre à l'intérieur du pays qu'on
est là pour le souhaitent pour le
soutenir pour être à ses côtés pour dire
aussi au pouvoir algérien qu'il est
temps qu'il parte
nous voulons un changement radical un
changement pacifique
nous voulons une transition démocratique
indépendante du pouvoir de 6 un bond
depuis 1962 à ce jour la situation est
restée telle qu il n y avait pas le
citoyen toujours vécu dans la soumission
et face à un pouvoir totalitaire qui
domine ce code dans tous les domaines et
depuis l'arrestation de khaled drr ni en
algérie plusieurs autres journalistes
ont été incarcérés ils sont accusés à
part les autorités de menaces et à
l'intérêt national est d'être à la seule
des deux parties étrangères au
classement mondial de la liberté de la
presse établi par reporters sans
frontières
l algérie pointe désormais à la 146e
place sur 180 et perd donc 27 places par
rapport à 2015